[Music]
this
is star talk neil degrasse tyson here
your personal astrophysicist
got with me my co-host jack nice hey hey
hey neil what's up all right
i love having you out there chuck i love
being here man for all my star talk
needs
you're there and and and beyond
and beyond and and beyond my friend
we're going to knock out another cosmic
queries but this one we have to
grab the ones that don't fit any
categories so this is just i think you
coined the term galactic gumbo
that's my favorite we we call it grab
bag we'll call it a bunch of different
things but my favorite is
the lightning gumball that outfit
so we should go to louisiana and see if
we can get galactic gumbo on somebody's
menu
oh wow that's oh that's a great i mean
why not yeah who's going to say no to
that right
exactly yo that's a great idea
oh that would nothing would make me more
uh happy than to go into
everything yeah so these are all
uh patreon uh questions and uh you know
they're getting it good parent i'm just
looking at it they are but
this time we actually let uh we have
more people than patreon
well you let in some others in this
round oh yeah this round
okay because it's it's ask anything
okay okay so and if i don't know i'll
just say i i don't know go on the next
question
that's right it could be anything that
they want to know from you
you know so um including you know why is
this guy blue but we already did that we
already did that we got that
yeah we did and you know the more
content we post chuck
right in explainer videos and things the
uh the whole cosmic queries could just
be
go to this link
right when we're done explaining
everything
and we we got it oh by the way i i have
to i'm compelled
that this format inspired a book
a star talk book called cosmic queries
it's it's uh march 2021 so
actual queries from people no so what
happens is there's some queries that are
just so
deep and and they spill out over this
format
someone says what is the meaning of our
existence or why is the universe here
those are real questions that real
people have right they don't lend
themselves to our repartee
right so we collected the deepest
questions ever asked
and we put them in the cosmic query's
book so it's like
um how did life get here what is the
universe made of
what's like why can't i wear brown shoes
with a black tuxedo
or can i wear white after labor day
those are the
questions the burning questions
okay cool start so start it out what you
got
all right let's let's go with uh um
um or um but
says chuck if you're reading this please
just call me sarah okay
okay well there you thanks sarah
thanks for telling me after you make a
fool of yourself right you could have
just
put that as your name okay
all right could dark matter be
uh the effect of another universe is
gravity
on our own gravity that's what i want it
to be
i so badly want dark matter to be
regular matter
in a parallel universe whose
gravitational force is spilling
into our space-time i want that to be
true
but none of my colleagues are leaning
that way and they're like deep in it and
it's their expertise
and i'm just looking over the fence what
you up to today picking it up so i can
share it
with all you good people so the the the
what's the over under the odds on
favorite is that there's some other kind
of particle
family of particles that are not the
electron proton neutron the ones we're
familiar with
that do not interact with our particles
and if they don't interact in any sort
of chemical way
then light will pass through them you
know they all you'll feel is their
gravity
and so i i don't have a problem with
that it i just
don't i don't think it's as fun as
thinking there could be another universe
now i the only reason why i think this
is i spoke with some top
folks about uh field theory
this is a class i never took in in
graduate school and i regret it
but feel fear you study you know fields
these are fields that that
generate forces on objects basically
okay okay it
turns out not the kind you play on not
the kind you play on
okay all right these are force fields
a concept introduced by um who's our
guide to mid-century mid-century of
faraday michael faraday
in the mid 19th century because no one
imagined describing something you can't
see
that has an effect on other things all
right and so he had to
invent this concept this field concept
where you draw lines that take the shape
of that field and that's what the iron
filings do for the magnetic field right
right
yeah before him it was just oh the the
the they're just
that's just what they do but he he gets
magic
so he gave it so he anchored it in in
physics speak so that we can actually
calculate with them and do other things
so so these are fields so in
field theory you apparently and i can't
demonstrate this to you i can only
repeat it others have told me
that light and all the forces that
surround it electromagnetic
forces cannot exit your space-time
they're trapped within it but gravity
can
gravity can spill out of your universe
and move between universes that's what i
heard and i i think i got that right
okay but i'd so if that's the case then
a nearby universe in this higher
dimensional um
construct could have gravity spilling
into our universe
and there we are mystically touching it
thinking it's a magical invisible thing
when it's just real and it's just
something sitting on outside the door
wow so now let me just ask this uh
on top of what she's you talked about
sarah
what sarah says thank you sarah
sarah sarah um
so you say that some think it would that
they might want it to be these particles
that
we cannot interact with yeah it's not so
much that they i think there's good
reason to think they could be those
particles and their experiments now
designed to try to capture them
and see if one in a zillion encounters
with our particles maybe they'll have
some uh there'll be
some exception to that rule that'll
render them visible
gotcha because that's my point it's like
what why
make that postulate in the first place
yeah yeah i mean what you know why not
just little gremlins you know i mean
there's an invisible particle you can't
see it right
you know so you have theories guiding
these experiments and they're suggesting
if the dark matter is of this kind
it should interact with this regular
particle in this way
this rarely or this frequently and so
you do this so we have these huge
experiments trying to detect
dark matter particles okay that's all
that's going on there all right so i'm
with sarah on this it'd be cool if it
were
okay very cool by the way if that's the
case
yes since we have since we have five
times as much dark matter
in our universe as regular matter don't
matter that means there's
a [ __ ] ton of regular matter in this
other universe
right they're regular matter right yeah
if our
dark matter is their regular matter that
universe has at least six at least
six times the mass at least but it turns
out to escape your universe and enter
another one
the strength of the gravity drops off
precipitously so it has to be
even stronger than just a factor of six
so
it's a honkering universe and wouldn't
it be weird if one day we learned
we're just some small gnat on the
among other gnats on the back of a much
larger more powerful universe
and we're just a satellite universe to
it
well that's in a way very humbling
and in a way i kind of want us all to
get together and just make a very loud
sound so that we are not
boiled in a pot of
water as the dust speck that we are
or to get swatted off the back but it
gets bang
all right wow okay cool all right okay
okay here we go
um uh also from patreon sarah was a
patreon patron and for those of you
interested go to patreon.com
and support us and uh and then you know
you can be part of um
actual private patreon cosmic queries
where neil answers your questions almost
personally
yeah these would just only be posted
behind the the the behind the curtain
behind the
patreon curtain all right fernando uh
gomes says this
our gomez or gomez you know it's
g-o-m-e-s so maybe it's gomez but it's
i if it's if it's freddy then
fine but it's fernando give me some okay
all right let me i'm sorry let me
allow me to recalibrate here we go
this is from fernando gomez
now starring
[Laughter]
maybe gomez needs a z and gomes is that
i don't know maybe i don't know
but anyway he says our own pocket of the
universe
is expanding will it exceed
the speed of light i guess when he's
saying expanding he's also
uh including the uh acceleration as well
uh and if so will that mean
uh will no more be able to detect
anything coming from outside of our
universe
two first of all that is already the
case
okay snap okay and as time moves on
and as you correctly added chuck with
the acceleration of the universe
what will happen is things that used to
be within our
horizon simply expand
faster than the light that they're
sending us can reach us
and then they basically disappear beyond
the horizon
and as the universe continues to expand
things that used to be nearby will now
find themselves on this
extreme limit of the expansion and then
disappear
beyond the horizon such that there will
be a day that arrives
by the way there's a whole section of
one of the chapters in the cosmic query
book on this by the way it's not out yet
it's like march so don't don't don't
worry about it yet not out yet
so so i don't even think it's listed yet
so i shouldn't even be talking about
them
so pretend i i didn't say anything hey
you're getting a sneak peek don't worry
okay so there there comes a time
when the our galaxy will merge
with the andromeda galaxy of becoming
one one galaxy twice the size
and it will become only us
in our pocket of the universe and all
other galaxies
would have receded beyond our horizon
and the night sky as seen from earth
would contain
only stars and nothing else in the
universe
so we would have a universe that people
thought it was
before hubble discovered other galaxies
there was a time what is it ask anybody
before 1926
they say tell me about the universe well
they're just stars stars in the night
sky and stars just go on
like forever and then we learned all the
stars you see are in our one little
galaxy
and there are island universes if you
will which was a term u
retraceable to immanuel kant and others
back in the 18th century
could there be island universes out
there so other galaxies you can think of
them that way
and so everything we know about the
history and origin of the universe is
because we can see
these other galaxies out to the edge of
the universe
but in the distant future when they all
recede beyond our horizon
gone is any record of
the history of the universe the big bang
the expansion
everything there'll be no indicators
left
to tell us it'll be an entire chapter
of the history of the universe ripped
from the book
and there you are any post-apocalyptic
civilizations
will say yeah the universe is just the
stars in the night sky
and they won't have any way to disprove
that
and chuck i lose sleep wondering
whether we today are in some kind of
state of existence where a chapter
had been removed from our attempt to
probe
our place in the universe and here we
are without that chapter
trying to make sense of it
oh that's terrible terrible what a
terrible
terrible thought i have these thoughts
and it
delays slumber
that's just awful that's an awful
thought oh my god yeah and so is the
distant future thought that's not good
either right uh
yeah i got another one you ready suppose
you grew up on venus you'd be vaporized
but let's ignore that complication
venus i got some really good sunscreen
if you
if you that won't help you from high
temperature this is true
that's only a uv sunscreen ain't
stopping you from right that's not 900
degrees
that's not it yeah i got an expec i got
an asbestos bathing suit
go ahead so uh if if civilization arose
on venus
right there would be no culture of the
night sky
there would be no night sky because it
has such a thick cloud cover
no one has ever seen the night sky oh
wow all you would know
is that half a year because venus
rotates very slowly half a year it's
just kind of light
and then it gets dark for most of you
and then it gets that's all you're gonna
know
and so someone would have to figure out
how to travel in space
to even know there's such a thing as
traveling in space
build a spaceship and then imagine
emerging from those clouds
the cloud tops for the first time and
you see the sun and stars
and other planets oh my gosh so are we
buried under some cloak preventing us
from getting
an accurate understanding of the world
around us wow
that's that's uh that that's very um
very profound and and thought-provoking
yeah
that's fernando there you go fernando
look at look at you buddy
we gotta take a quick break when we come
back more cosmic queries uh galactic
gumbo
edition
we're back jack yeah chuck do you get to
do stand up during covet how does that
work
okay so it's so funny that you asked
that
i have done a few zoom shows to be
honest
uh and they feel weird um
and i yeah because so much of your of
your
business model as a comedian is
interacting with people and seeing them
and feeling them
right you can't do comedy in a vacuum no
it's weird and uh but
on zoom that that's kind of fun because
depending on who's hosting the show they
sometimes they let you you know you can
see into these people's homes
and so that you don't you smack talk
what's going on
that that that is so much fun there's
so so much fun it's like
it's it's like you know if i were doing
a zoom right now in a comedy show and
i'm looking at
neil degrasse tyson i'd be like oh look
at that there's dr tyson who
apparently has uh pictures of alien
sperm on his wall
that's great that is fantastic this
guy's clearly been off the planet
okay so you know that's the fun part but
it's it's not nearly as fun as doing
stand-up live with the energy of a live
audience there's a
there's a real human connection that
comes with a live audience there's
nothing like that so
just for those only listening i have two
works of art from an
inuit artist yes and it is a
bird that has just consumed a
a fish and one is a black and white
version the other one is a white and
black version of the same print
and they flank my desk
for these recordings and they they look
they do look a little alien
yeah they do they agree with you they
look a little alien but they're cool
and if you're interested in these you
can find them on on our postings
uh the name of the artist and the
and a little bit of the history of the
inuit culture is there
so and and i thank her for giving me
permission to show these
uh i mean they're actually our real art
my wife is from uh
was raised in alaska and so she has sort
of an awareness
and a sensitivity to the whole region
and inuit art and this sort of thing
so that's cool yeah anyhow so let's keep
going give me some questions yeah let's
let's get back into uh let's do another
patreon another patreon from
jet thomas what a good name he's a
he's a he's a space hero uh
hello neil and chuck if gravitational
waves can bend the fabric of space-time
wait wait by the way jets don't work in
space just so you know you need rockets
but go on
okay you're right because you need to
air in through the air
you need air inflow to to to make a jet
i'm just saying
i i got you i got you okay okay listen
i'm not
i will i will take that correction i'm
gonna be all up in your face about it
i won't let stuff go by i know who i'm
talking around
okay that's why i don't go to the movies
with you
all right here we go so jet thomas says
this
if gravitational waves can bend the
fabric of space-time
could it potentially be utilized to
communicate
with life in other universes
in principle could a device use
gravitational waves
instead of the way we use uh radio waves
to stream
information outside the bounds of our
universe now
you just said in our previous answer
that light is bound to this universe
trapped so now gravitational waves
yeah so each one of these is an entire
window
to the universe i mean let's think back
for a minute
when the telescope was sort of pioneered
by
galileo he's thinking oh my gosh
look what i can now see and i can look
at i can see ships farther in the
distance i can look up at the milky way
and i see stars where you thought it was
just a cloud
and he's imagining that the telescope is
the way to see
everything your eyes can't okay
right but then give me a couple hundred
years on that
and then what happens william herschel
discovers infrared
which is also light but your eyes can't
see it and in fact is
in his original research paper he called
it light unfit for vision
wow and so wait a minute if all your
telescopes are only giving you
visible light but why even call it
visible light it's just light right you
don't have any other
you know there's no reason to qualify
that it's
visible light if you don't know any of
the light that you can't see the moment
we discover
light you can't see you now have to
constrain
how you call the light your eyes detect
and we call that visible light
infrared is not visible ultraviolet is
not visible neither are x-rays gamma
rays radio waves
none of that yet it's all light
traveling at
the speed of light so we open up
telescopes to these windows
to the universe and that's how we
discovered the birth of the universe and
black holes and
and and jets all kinds of things in the
universe that's how we discovered them
but now we can go a step beyond that and
say
all of these collectively in a way
is just one kind of window to the
universe the window that uses light
are there other kinds of windows and yes
gravitational waves is a kind of window
neutrinos is a kind of window the
neutrinos everywhere we just need
special telescopes to detect them and so
if
gravity if gravity can escape your
universe
if that can happen then there's no
reason why we can't send a signal
i i agree entirely that's a long answer
to just say
no i agree but but i got a question that
again i'm
i'm an idiot when it comes to field
theory so
if the ripple of a gravitational wave
it requires or
its effect in the space-time continuum
is this
wave when it leaves the universe what is
it jiggling
i mean i don't know what is it maybe
it's just the graviton
the the quantum particle that
corresponds to the gravity wave
in this same way a photon of light
corresponds to the wave of light
right these are sort of parallel
constructs all right
we speak of light waves they're carried
by photons gravity waves carried by
gravitons
maybe the graviton busts out goes
through comes
enters the other universe and we don't
have to worry about the wave
warping the fabric of space and time so
yeah i don't see why not but i would
need higher expertise to
answer that with some precision wow that
well
god how much higher expertise can you
get
yeah that's his thing that's right yeah
that was a great answer though man
no that's that's fantastic yeah i love
it and
the windows to the universe that's an
excellent yeah so what it is it's a
window
so the electromagnetic spectrum is a
window of windows
right right and then we have another
kind of window over here on the other
side of the house
see oh man i love that i love that
that's just
god that's if you went back in time and
said galileo you're practically blind
right and he said no i'm not look what i
can see
he was like do you not see what i'm
looking through
what the hell is wrong with you that's
exactly how he would have said it too
yeah you know that's how he
dude to you what
he he was colloquial by the way he
didn't he he hung with the with the
common folk
oh really he might have spoken in the
italian vernacular
of the day whatever that would have been
yes the italian equivalent of child
please
so okay cool job
you know i am better at the telescope
from the inner cities
oh that's hilarious okay here we go here
we go
uh i love that the window the different
windows of the universe love it
okay let's go to eric allen eric allen
also from patreon and then we're going
to jump into other
people outside of patreon i'll make eric
the last patreon question
hi there i've been listening for years
and i
finally have the nerve to ask a question
he says we know that the force of
gravity bleeding into our universe from
another universe would drop
off at the rate of one over r cubed he
says yeah
okay uh hypothetically if the
other three forces were somehow able to
bleed into our universe
uh from another would they be
affected the same way now i don't know
if i said his equation correct i got it
no we're good we we
we good here okay so let me just say
what's going on here
yes please okay um if i have a water
pistol
okay and i shoot it right at your face
right then all the water that exited
the the vessel in the water pistol
goes in a stream and it all lands on
your nose
right okay if you're a good shot there's
no there's no
dilution of as long as the stream is is
tight
and narrow there's no dilution of it
of what came out of my water gun before
it hits your face
so now let me say i'm now instead of
gonna
do it in a straight line that's one
dimension i'm gonna spray it
horizontally okay okay but it's the same
amount of water
same amount of water okay so if i if now
i
spray it then it has it's
quote diluted by the area over which it
has to
travel okay so if that's the case
then it drops off as um
one over r is what one over the distance
so
if you're twice as far away you're
getting half as much as you would have
if you were
closer okay that's how that dilution
would work
so that's in two dimensions okay now
let's say
you're now spraying it
in all three dimensions so that now it's
now it's like this
this wave the spherical wave
emanating from the water gun of course
you'll hit yourself in the face yeah
because it's going in all directions
right right right
so it turns out if you go in all these
directions
then it's being diluted by the area of
the surface of that sphere
okay that's it so now it's being delete
and it's the the formula for the surface
of a sphere is four pi r
squared so it's being diluted by the
square
of the size of the the surface and so
this is the famous one over r
squared law that light experiences
that gravity experiences because
whatever is the source
it goes out and it's filling all of
space and as it moves out the intensity
drops off
as the square if you're leaving your
universe you're going in a direction
that is not accessible to anything you
have seen or know
because you're exiting these dimensions
and now you're exit and you're leaving
our universe crossing into another
universe
the strength of the gravity when i'll
drop off by the cube of the distance
and that's significant okay
if i'm two feet away and now i go to
four feet
i now have one eighth the strength right
not half the strength not half the
strength
because it's a factor of two away and
you cube that two times two times two is
eight
right i have one one-eighth the strength
okay so
i don't know any reason to think why
other forces wouldn't have this extra
dimension of dilution
associated with him exiting your
universe and coming into the
uh another universe right okay cool
wow yeah so you're subject to a higher
dimension of dilution
by leaving a universe and so yeah so so
that's why i think i said in an earlier
question
it's not only the six times our
gravity that it has going on for itself
it's got to make up for that extra
dilution to leave its universe and come
in here
so it's a honkering universe wow okay
cool if that's
if that's how if if that's what we're
feeling if that's what dark matter
actually is
yeah well i got to tell you eric after
waiting years you actually came up with
a damn good question
good for you buddy uh yeah
yeah we'll see in a few years with
another great question
let's keep it going with uh oh i love
this
this is from instagram the most happy
boy
11 is the handle
neil how does it all end
oh and that's it that's it that's the
whole question
how does it all end uh let me tell you
what that is when we return
we got to take a quick break and when we
come back the third and final segment
of cosmic queries galactic gumbo gravity
on star talk we back
star talk cosmic queries yes all right
uh
if we let we last left off last week's
episode
we the question was asked by who was it
little boy 11 or something what is it
uh yeah most happy boy 11. most happy
boy 11.
yeah i wanted to know how will it all
end
yes the universe
will end
not in light but in dark
not in fire but in ice
not with a bang but with a whimper oh
oh that's terrible okay or a poor
universe
beyond that little bit of simple
language
okay there's an entire section of the
cosmic queries book
that specifically addre addresses all
the scenarios
of how we will end and so i'm going to
be i'm going to pull rank here and say
buy the damn book when it comes out
oh wow there you go what i will do i
hate doing that but it's
a lot of effort went into those chapters
are going to pluck for me
the scariest ending of them all okay
good i like that all right
wait okay hold on let me get my
flashlight
all right
chuck imagine he's around a campfire
in the dark but he's in a completely lit
room right okay exactly right
so here you go this expansion of the
universe this acceleration
there's no reason for any of us to think
it will ever end
it will keep accelerating in its
expansion
so it as we described earlier the
galaxies the distant galaxies will
expand beyond our horizon
then the nearby ones will no longer be
nearby because they would have been
stretched to the edge of the universe
then the power of the stretching will
overcome
the gravitational binding of
stars with other stars and stars with
their planets
so we would see our galaxy
systematically get stripped apart
with stars being cast beyond the horizon
as it expands
and this will continue at so not only
will every star
get cast asunder to beyond our horizon
such that our sky will contain only one
star
and that is the sun except the sun won't
live that long let's pretend it's still
there
then the stretching of the universe will
rip the planets
away from the star so that we will then
become alone in our own bubble
within our own horizon in the universe
then
it will keep stretching and it will
begin ripping the earth
apart and by the way this is happening
at a faster and faster
rate and you can calculate when
the expansion of the universe rips apart
the very particles that comprise
matter itself and and the very
the very um the what's called a plank
length
the very um the granularity of the
quantum universe itself
gets ripped apart and in fact this is
called the big rip
oh my oh the universe split its pants
oh my goodness i mean literally
yeah it split everything
wow it bent over it split its pants i
chuck i love that description
and that if the universe goes that way
it'll happen between 10 to the 30 and 10
to the 35 years around there
okay so that's a lot that's a lot of
years in the future so there you go
happy boy i hope you lose sleep over
there
and we ain't happy anymore
well by the way there was an episode of
doctor who where there was a tear
in the face in the space-time fabric and
that tear
would show up and you would like see it
and so that was particularly scary for
me because i know what
you know what what the theories tell us
but
yeah so the big rip freaking me out the
big rip all right let it freak you out
too so i'm not the only one
there you go all right oh by the way and
that's just one of a dozen scenarios
given in that chapter
oh cool okay excellent all right and
read it to your kids
people bedtime stories it's a wonderful
bedtime story
wonderful all right here uh this is
chloe wagstaff chloe wagstaff says this
uh how can artists in your opinion
contribute to science they already are
oh my gosh so first of all historically
before we had cameras the especially
the naturalists but also astronomers too
if you saw something
you just drew it all right and not all
scientists are good at drawing so you
see galileo sketches they're not too bad
right in his notebook they're pretty
good better than i can do i think but if
you had a real artist
they could totally rock the scene and
put what is actually out there on the
page
and all the naturalists who are who are
documenting
flora and fauna of the world as they
traveled the world
to record all the manifestations of life
on earth
every one of those were either artists
themselves or carried an artist
in in the back you know in the wagon
with them
and so one of the most famous of these
are the audubon paintings
all right you know we hold them up as
art but this is this is a scientific
record
of birds and until photography could do
that or do it well or capture the color
of them
that was the only thing we had so we owe
it a tremendous debt
of gratitude to artists the scientific
illustrators
of the day but then when photography
came it sort of
relaxed that requirement and but there
were still some things you had to draw
because photography wasn't all that
sensitive to light so if it was really
really dim you still had to draw it
early astronomical images were still
drawn even though
photography was available well let's
fast forward to today
so no we don't sorry i don't need you to
draw my hubble
uh photo because we got really good
imagery of it
sorry however you know what i need you
for you know what i want you for
design graphic design they're artists
okay i like
some things better than others even if
they have the same functionality
because some objects are just beautiful
to behold or to touch
or to to to carry with you
i value that i think that's you know we
can have a utilitarian world
but is that the world you want to choose
to live in no you want the world where
that's a beautiful space that's a
beautiful architecture now that's a
beautiful
um building a beautiful room it's been
organized beautifully what's the feng
shui of that room
those aren't scientists thinking that up
those are artists
so you just described apple computers
i tried not to mention the name because
you know we're we're not paid by apple
or anything
yeah but but there's still time there's
still time
so in that way artists i think
make a beautiful world in which
scientists function
but but otherwise no i don't
see that happening there's a big push to
get a in
steam right science technology
engineering and math
you put an a in there and stem becomes
steam and with the urge that if you
train scientists to be artists it can
boost their creativity
and i don't know how successful that
will be yes you have to be creative
as a scientist but the number of
scientists who said
you know i thought about this new
discovery
after i looked at this work of art or
after i painted this
that those numbers are not high and
i know of one case a guy named ed
belbruno
who looked at starry night by van gogh
and it got him thinking about orbits
transfer orbits between earth and the
moon because of the swirls
of the paint so it got him thinking i
think that's great does it mean he would
have never had those thoughts without
seeing the painting i don't know i do
know however
that science and engineering greatly
affect art
right when when neon was invented or
discovered you could have neon glowing
tubes
artists were all over it with neon
sculptures and things and
and so when we make chemical that's uh
uh discoveries or discoveries in
material science
or in computing the artists are all in
it
and all over it there'd be no modern
special effects
were it not for artists exploiting the
computing foundations that were created
by basically
um math geeks 60 years ago
so there is a there is a two-way street
but most of the traffic really goes
to towards the artists rather than
towards the science but based on my read
of the history of this well there you
have it
um uh artists you guys you're not
we don't need you
now you know that's a joke don't know
let me say let me say differently
maybe if more scientists took art class
then there would be more creativity
expressed than they believed possible
right okay but i want to see that tested
and i think it's worth an experiment
yeah i think i want to see scientists
take communications classes
more than i want to see them think
we need people to listen to scientists
um
you know more than anything and one last
then one last bit of that i don't
want to eat up this whole segment on
this but if you look at beethoven's
ninth symphony or even van gogh's starry
night
if they didn't create those no one ever
to be born will ever create them
they are singular expressions of the
creativity of those artists
whereas if einstein had never discovered
relativity somebody else would have or
some combination of people would have
and they would have discovered it in
exactly
the way he showed it to us
and so the creativity of a scientist
is not existing in a in a in a
free thinking way
because ultimately nature passes
judgment
on whether what you invented works at
all
so the creative process has different
landing zones
no that makes sense that makes sense
because science
is bound by laws where it's like laws
that we didn't create they're actually
create yeah creativity is about breaking
laws
i like to very nicely put exactly cool
all right
yeah let's go to lightning round see how
many questions we can get in okay here
we go
um all right i don't know if we're going
to lightning round with this question
because it's a great question this is ms
kell 88.93
what questions are we not
and should be asking about the universe
damn oh
yes i mean that's really cool
all right i got one you ready go ahead
okay the question
that we should be asking and we're not
have not yet manifested because the
discoveries necessary for us to occupy
the new vista
which enables those questions to then be
in sight
of our curiosity have yet to be
discovered
oh my god you thought about this before
next question
oh my god okay i'm just going to say
that was a really good answer man okay
next question all right next question
here we go
vitesh sinha who says uh do you believe
in a borderless world um and how could
we possibly make that happen
uh borderless earth no countries no
countries
yeah okay okay so this is borderless
earth okay so i don't mean when world i
was
i mean the universe but earth yeah i
think borders are embarrassing
they're just embarrassing if an alien
came down and said are you all human
yeah so well then why is this guard
right here
why are you why is there a war oh
because
even though we're all human we're
finding reasons to kill each other
uh these slight differences that we
tried hard to find
found them and invoke them as reasons to
mistreat each other to kill each other
to enslave people
to round them up into concentration
camps and so
uh yeah we have to somehow tell that to
the aliens
as they look at us befuddedly like what
the hell is wrong with you
they'll go back there's no sign of
intelligent life on earth
um often a common enemy brings people
together
kovid should have been that enemy where
we'd say let's put down the
you know our differences and fight this
because it will attack us all
no matter who we worship or who we have
sex with or who we
all the other things that creates fights
among us
we have a common enemy people let's
fight it together and that didn't even
happen
i gave us a d plus on that okay
uh the only reason i don't give it an f
is because some progress was made
in the effort to make um the
vaccines right so uh
i don't have hope i think deep down
within our dna
our tribalism will forever prevent that
from happening
and i wish i could sound more positive
but based on my read of history i can't
well a sobering answer to say the least
you know chuck i think we have to i
think we gotta end there chuck no
get out of here all right wait wait one
last one very one last one okay go
okay sour uh pandov says this uh
has humankind ever seen in the night sky
a supernova good one
so first we discover hundreds of them
are the year with dedicated telescopes
dedicated telescopes
that go from galaxy to galaxy looking
for something that blew up
since last night okay uh supernova lasts
you know
visibility last weeks and into the
months so you wait so we have
dedicated experiments just for that
purpose but for the
unaided eye the first exploding star
visible since kepler in the 1600s
was in 1987. there was a guy in the
observatories in chile in the andes
mountains who is looking through his
telescope
and he sees this bright object and what
he's looking at and he says
no there's something wrong with the
telescope so he says let me just walk
he goes outside the telescope looks up
there's a bright object
okay so this is a case where he's using
his
eyes to verify the machine rather than
the machine to verify his eyes
and that was discovered i think in
february in the year
1987 it was the first supernova
discovered that year
and is the famous 1987a
and it is the most studied supernova
in the history of the world and all our
telescopes we have a very good
communication system among us
all the telescopes around the world
abandoned whatever research projects
they were on at the time
slewed in the sky over and found this
object and even when it was below the
horizon
the telescope's waiting for it to rise
so you can get all kinds of data
radio waves infrared ultraviolet visible
everything
every everything we could throw at it we
did
and there are thousands of research
papers on that exploding star
visible to the naked eye well there you
have it yeah google that 1987 capital a
it's all there all right beautiful
question we chuck that's it we got it
we got a wrap all right all right that
was fun
yeah yeah yeah yeah very good so all
right chuck ah
i'll be looking for you i love your
twitter feed especially when you live
tweet
live events yeah yeah not much of that
going on now but i'll be i'll be
tweeting the super bowl that's the super
bowl i'll be looking for that
yeah because you you don't you don't
play with the c
you don't give cut anybody slack no
they're all jokes
everybody should be able to take it
[Laughter]
all right this has been star talk cosmic
query is a gumbo galactic gamboa
with spice on this version uh so i've
been your host neil degrasse tyson as
always
keep looking up